credo fortemente che non esista nulla di
più bello di ciò che state per vedere
ho fatto questo video in collaborazione
con il gatto che uno youtuber bellissimo
come me vi vorrei spiegare che cosa
state però vi giuro che non ri e non
riuscirei a farlo buona visione e
godetevi il video come funziona qualche
non vi allora so fare funziona che una
volta permuta e viene sparato nella
direzione doodle screw van dyer cos'è
non lo so però ci separiamo ma andiamo
adesso sito di passare in mezzo a una
pala eolica e niente non ci arriverò
incredibile nero due metri ho fatto e si
qua c'è una persona la picchio ero io
sono io era lei a non le ricorda il
gladiatore questa cosa
[Musica]
parole già un tasto per far parte la
musica sì me lo faccia se è veramente
azzecca e va beh esagero esagero
dura la prossima volta poi col biglietto
aveva adocchiato una persona l'agio però
non lo vedo più quindi niente magari mi
sono sbagliato cos'è qua
guardi qua guardi qui signor gatto non
lo usi in casa lo non lo uso e parto lei
no sembrano fuori e non è funzionale
questo coso sono stato buttato terra io
è mannaggia aspetti che stop la donna
razzi dentro la casa ma non ma ce n'è un
altro li venga fuori mega sparire le
sparo esco l'ha preso no a questo c'è un
mito incredibile male scolo presbiti
risulto per l'arrivo skill gatto massimi
a casa arrivo a risistemare non puoi
uscire o grasselli in frame da quanto
tempo ho ucciso due persone e fortissima
quest arma contro meglio perso tutte le
mie armi perché quando viene colpito ti
cadono tutte le cose dalle ma non lo so
non lo sapete però poi questo a un'amica
una mitraglia una lunga ombra un esimi
faccia vedere quando la juve calibro ma
questo era in maglia che male ma già dal
traspare noi c'è gente ucciso anche lui
il bravissimo sono fortissimi ha
lamentato più su questo fucile laser
spara laser
[Musica]
l'america è stato veramente divertente
colpi ancora incidente qua mi spari
aiuto cento e non ne faccio subito io
dovevo fare signor gatto facciamo
qualcosa raggiri ma comunque la spada
cima sagra ma mi scusi è stato belli ho
fatto fuori cinque persone aiutavano in
rehab viveva bene
ecco siamo già in partito siamo già in
particolare la mia resta però istantanee
alla cosa questo non è lei mi sa cos'è
questa roba che se preme la g inizia un
rap l'agi la gente è vero c'è un viaggio
nel giallo anche sulla mappa di vado
vederlo porca vacca che brutta cosa ne
pensavo così tanto sparato eccomi le
salve
che bello è stato il menù è la cosa più
bella che abbiamo e sacre morale pando
vero sto ancora leccando dai venga che
le do un piccolo passaggio i veicoli
sono presi allora mi faccia mi faccia
apprezzare un secondo la dinamica di
questa faccenda qui non posso entrare
non si fondano due anzi si fonda in due
vada vada che già si sparano che queste
visto pericolosi è la cosa più bella che
abbia mai visto
non vedo niente vedo solo le sue spalle
però è bellissimo
grazie gentilissimo dietro abbiamo una
macchina grossissima che sta per i
borghi citran 3 2 1 e stato bello
giocare con lei venga qui va beh io
continuate sono morto forma e metà vita
a metà vita ne hanno investito forti
sono shariff mario laser spari il pari
pari il campo il signor gatto spari e
niente qui per domani picchio l'ho
picchiato però non so se è morto
ora vivo ma di prima puglia è morto oggi
l'ho ucciso io voglio tu mi è stato
molto bello
gli elementi grazie è nato per giocare
questo gioco lei è bravissimo ha visto
guardi le do un piede di porco l'aringa
troppo gentile come si prendono le app
che ti faccio vedere cosa si vede quando
per mezza faccia vedere va bene tom
clancy's esatto la seguo faccia strada
l'abbiamo ok di qua bene se viene dentro
la se li fa mi scusi premi presi non
volevo assolutamente fare tesoro
che succede ci sono armi ok allora
seconda mai una stana grenade mai
sbagliato va bene non sbagliati
pagherebbe non fa niente e le sparano i
sì che la mamma mia che la copra la
coprono essi e niente e poi ti aspetti
che c'è un problema l'ho capito al mese
posto un po perché colpito f sur e
surreale niente mi hanno ucciso
ma quando sparì io non sono proprio
convinto che va dal colpo dove lei sta
sparando perché la vedo troppe il
problema deve capire che noi siamo
persone hanno dei personaggi un po small
e già ti come può vedere anche da questa
animazione noto alle dat
faccio notare che nella mappa c'è il
talk asso che è scritto un po a cazzo è
vero e lui li composto scritto malevole
non possiamo andare lì e va bene dai
ma dov'è questo talk ha chiamato avanti
mannaggia è anche sopra la cima ai a
chiama le triple sono dentro ma si
l'aspetto qui le armi si abbia mi
raccomando sai che paura
sono pronto a dirigerla venga venga
venga si fidi
oddio da come sta tenendo l'arma appunto
significhi che ho le mani salde sul mare
l'ufficio di vado ecco la sto
apprezzando non so se vale non ci siamo
neanche passati di là però va bene ecco
loco in gta spari forte il bravissimo
sto sparando anche io mentre guido non
so come stia succedendo questa se si
avvicina moltissimo con la doppietta
io mi stanno investendo per la donna che
male è cosa scappando sto scappando
paris paris il cactus è vero sto
sparando può avere il dio aiuto ma che
mai ma davanti a spari che fermo è morto
è morto non è morto non è morto ma è
bravissimo e niente finché non
ammazziamo lui non smettiamo dove dove
grande artista sinistra eccolo eccolo è
sceso venga verso di me venga qui eccola
con venga qui l'ho preso l'ho ucciso non
è morto non con mano morire a fotterci
le macchine nord ha ucciso ecco
finalmente valute è era proprio cattivo
di faccia c'è uno è una persona qui con
una porta sulla schiena sparo io ci ho
preso sul sicuro e la porta lo protegge
un problema esatto la porta veramente
invalicabile ma possono che suscitare
quelli delle la gente e avversari cosa
sta succedendo lì dentro me perché io
dai perché no uno mi ha ucciso con una
spada come l'età fare il mio byyou venga
venga aiuto lega qui che no niente mi
hanno finito è stato bellissimo ma mai
premuto tab mentre sul treno berto se è
veramente bello ma come nella vita vertu
6 bebè questo cambio stipato eccolo qui
in quanto ingegnoso che perlo quanto si
vola tra l'altro si vola tantissimo ma
ndo da un muro va bene potevate la
scheda non è accettata tanta gente credo
dal kicker e dal fumo
prato la porta la porta della schiena è
molto bene e ho tratto un cecchino hanno
alcun arma di prima che arrivo vedo
persone però questo potrebbe essere un
problema
persone che tutte storte
asparano io sparo alle persone hanno
ucciso cervo o un cecchino se vuole
arrivo sono dalle aiace gente qua
tantissima ayachi male fuori entry john
cervo in mezzo alle balle è vero quanto
difficile da uccidere la gente è certo è
che ho finito i colpi guardate a ucc
prossimo bravissimo fette che prendo le
cose ok porta è veramente comoda davvero
pratico infatti pensati in altolago
eccolo mi sento ma che brutta cosa
allora non è ma che silenzi tar ha
silenziato così guarda che bello e
andrebbero che mai che kimi sparagli chi
spara chi è che spara non li vedo una
suora che marley una suora
eccole
maggia no non è vero signor gare non si
arrivò mai come dove non c'è gente qui
da me procedente
ho sparato alla sua ora come il p ta
forte però provare arrivarci eno eccolo
lì è però e c'è la persona il proprio
parlato di lei come fa il vuoto noi ci
prova sembra ci provo mannaggia
guarda il postino vestito di rosa va dal
signore giu arrivo arrivo al nostro
finito anche i col scappi si salvi
scappi aiuto per poco la porta
sto usando la porta per difendermi però
non so quanto può non pensi a me ip sono
spagnoli vedo neanche più
ok come non detto mi sono stati dipenda
ci provo quanto storto aiuto quali
finiranno i corpi di due morti sono
bravissimo avuto altro a zero quindi
fatta è quasi vinta
l'hack è male
ci avevo creduto va bene per me io sono
sono ok in cerata non avrei mai
abbastanza giocherei tutto il giorno
però in the ragazzi spero che le sia qui
che le sia piaciuto tantissimo
ben detto mi piace mettermi piace signor
gava io vi ringrazio e vi ci vediamo un
altro episodio di come si chiama total i
accorrete sbatte al gran che veramente
in gioco che merita iscrivetevi anche
karel e il signor gatto che lasci in
descrizioni e noi ci vediamo un passo
video più bella ragazza
[Musica]